and i i've built a career out of  self-deprecating humor that's what i've  built my career on  and  i don't want to do that anymore  because do you  understand you understand what  self-deprecation means when it comes  from somebody who already exists in the  margins  it's not humility  it's humiliation  i put myself down in order to speak in  order to seek permission to speak  and i simply will not do that anymore  not to myself or anybody who identifies  with me  i've had planter's warts that were  funnier  than that and to top off the unfunniness  there's also just the the whininess  the woe is me stuff hannah says she's on  the margins she's marginalized no you're  not that's not what marginalized looks  like you have a netflix deal